Europa, Ganymede, Enceladus.
All moons in our solar system
with one thing in common:
They're suspected to contain liquid water
below their icy surfaces.
And even further out,
we have some tantalizing
evidence that maybe worlds around
Neptune and potentially
even Uranus as well
could host liquid water.
Even Pluto might have
a layer of liquid water
hiding somewhere
underneath that icy crust.
Experts think that
if there is life beyond Earth,
these massive oceans are
the place we're most likely
to find it in our solar system.
NASA scientists and oceanographers
are working towards
missions that hopefully
will end up looking for
and hopefully finding
some forms of life,
which may be very different from ours
on those other planetary bodies.
There's an increasing number of missions
and proposals to explore
these untapped water bodies,
starting with an expedition
to one of Jupiter's moons.
It's called the Europa Clipper Mission.
Europa Clipper Mission
is NASA's next foray
into the Jupiter system,
and we're going to search
for all of these amazing
indicators of habitability and
potentially life at Europa.
Exploring our solar system's
subsurface water oceans
is one of the next big
steps in space exploration.
In 1977, during a mission
to photograph the barren, volcanic floor
along the mid-ocean ridge,
scientists found something
that totally changed
our understanding of where life can exist.
They collected 3,000
photos of the sea floor,
developed the film onboard the ship.
And as they were going
through the footage,
which was very boring
because it was just barren volcanic rock,
they came across 13 photos
that had pictures of large clams in them.
Shortly after that,
the deep submersible
Alvin that takes people
to the bottom of the ocean
arrived on the scene
and dived on those sites
and found the oases of life,
amidst all sorts of shimmering water
that was clearly emanating
out of the sea floor.
The seawater percolating into the seafloor
was being heated by magma
and then rising to discharge
as hydrothermal vents,
and those vents were supporting
a previously unknown ecosystem.
Before then, it was thought that
most animal life depended
on energy from the sun.
If you move more than
about 50 to 100 meters
away from a vent, the seafloor is barren.
And the question is
how do these vents support the life?
Well, clearly photosynthesis,
on which most of our life
relies on our planet,
won't work at the bottom of
the ocean because it's dark,
and so there's no sunlight,
so that photosynthesis
will not be operative.
However, we do have these gases
that contain a lot of energy.
And because of that, there are bacteria
living around these areas
and other microorganisms
that are able to extract energy
from those gases
and use it to produce organic matter.
And that matter feeds an array
of exotic animals.
When I first saw them,
my mind was blown
at several things.
One how beautiful they are,
but also how big some of the animals are.
Some of the creatures
that you see down there
are tube worms that can
grow 6 to 10 feet long,
foot-long clams, big mussels.
And in fact, the diversity
around these vents
has been likened to that of the diversity
of a tropical rainforest.
This discovery has big implications
for planetary bodies in
the universe with water,
regardless of whether or
not they're close enough
to harness the energy of their host star.
It suggests that there's
a possibility that
there might be life on
other planetary bodies
that have water.
And so in some ways,
this discovery is helping
change our ideas about
the potential for life on other planets.
In the decades
since the hydrothermal vent discovery,
evidence has piled up for oceans
in the outer solar system.
Both the Galileo probe
that visited Jupiter
and the Cassini probe that visited Saturn
were equipped with an onboard
device called a magnetometer,
which was able to give substantial
evidence for liquid oceans.
Think of it as like a fancy compass.
Basically any liquid water ocean,
if it has salts in it, it
can conduct electricity.
And that means that if
you have a world nearby
like Jupiter or Saturn, that
has its own magnetic field,
they can influence each other,
and we can pick that
up with a magnetometer.
So this is how Galileo was able to provide
tantalizing evidence
of liquid water oceans
around Europa and a couple of other moons
in the Jovian system.
But life, as far as we know,
needs more than water.
There needs to be an
energy source like the sun
or similar processes that
create hydrothermal vents.
So when the Voyager mission flew past
Jupiter's moon Io in 1979
and witnessed volcanic plumes,
scientists were thrilled to confirm
that these frozen bodies were more active
than previously thought.
So we thought that the further
out we got from the sun,
the less interesting the
solar system would be.
Boy were we wrong.
Europa is far away from the sun.
It's five times farther than Earth.
And that means that it's much colder.
Europa should be frozen
solid, but it's not.
Why is that?
Well, we think that there are two reasons.
The first is heat that's generated by
radioactive elements in Europa's core.
This is similar to how
Earth's interior stays
molten and really hot.
As certain elements decay,
they give off some heat,
but we don't think that could be enough.
The other thing that we
think is keeping Europa warm
is something called tidal heating.
Now this happens because as
Europa orbits around Jupiter,
its orbit is not a perfect circle.
Instead, it's a bit of an ellipse.
And that means when Europa
is orbiting Jupiter,
sometimes it's a little bit closer,
sometimes it's a bit further away.
And so the moon actually goes like this
and that title flexing generates heat
just as if you were to, you
know, rub your hands together,
you'd generate some heat
due to that friction.
So we think that that
also is helping to keep
Europa's ocean liquid
potentially for a very,
very long time.
Tidal heating is also the reason
for the volcanic activity
on Io observed by Voyager.
But there are other
reasons for making Europa
the top priority.
While some moons in our solar
system have many craters,
Europa has few.
And this means that the
surface is probably very young
due to an ocean that causes
the surface to warm and crack,
changing the landscape
and erasing craters.
Based off of what we know of Europa now,
we know it has a liquid water ocean.
We know it has some building blocks
that could potentially be used
for organic molecules to make life.
And we know it has an energy source.
So all of these lines of
evidence point towards
having the ingredients for life.
Not only that, but this
intense tidal heating
could lead to hydrothermal vents
down at the sea floor of Europa.
And so this is why it's
at the top of our list
to study as a world that
could host life of its own.
Now all we need to do is get there.
Europa Clipper is prepared
to launch in 2024.
We have really amazing cameras
that are gonna take
higher-resolution images
than ever before.
We've got some imaging spectrometers.
These are instruments that
will be able to tell us
what the composition of the surface is.
We'll have a magnetometer,
a fancy compass to be able to understand
more about Europa's interior ocean.
We'll even have a radar sounder
so that we can look for near-surface
water reservoirs too.
In addition to that,
we're going to have a few other particles
and fields instruments
to try to understand
the plasma environment.
All of those ions that are zipping around
in the Jupiter system,
we'll be able to understand those
because they're important too.
Color and infrared cameras
will map the surface
and search for hotspots where
material from within Europa,
possibly the ocean, may reach the surface.
It will be the first mission sent
to specifically study a
moon other than our own.
The mission will place
the Clipper spacecraft,
which is longer than a basketball court,
in orbit around Jupiter,
where it will perform
about 40 flybys of Europa.
Now ideally we would love to send Clipper
and go straight into orbit around Europa,
but the conditions in the Jovian system
don't make that the best option for us.
There's a bit of radiation that's right in
and around where Europa sits
in orbit around Jupiter.
And while that's not
necessarily bad for life,
in fact, it could make some molecules
and some ions that might be good for life,
it's not so good for our spacecraft.
So instead we're planning
on doing flybys of Europa,
where we go in, we get our data,
we get out, we cool off for a bit,
send that data back to
Earth, and it gives us
as scientists plenty of
time to look over things
before the next pass.
The spacecraft may even be able to sample
particles high above Europa's surface.
During past Earth observations
and observations from the
Hubble Space Telescope,
scientists have seen
something that looks like
plumes of water or other
material on Europa.
Clipper will be equipped
with the right tools,
and will be able to fly close enough
to analyze those plumes
if they do indeed exist.
This would be similar to
Saturn's moon Enceladus,
where free sample from its ocean,
is actively venting into space.
Now, this would be really exciting for us
because some of the instruments
aboard Europa Clipper
could collect some of those ice grains
if they're there or some of the gases
and be able to tell us
what they're made of
and help us get a glimpse of
the composition of that ocean.
Although the main goal of Clipper
is to understand habitability on Europa,
not all of the questions regarding life
can be answered from flybys.
That's why NASA is proposing
a follow-up mission
to launch in the next couple of decades
that could land on Europa.
The Europa Lander mission concept
is something that we've been developing
that could potentially
visit a world like Europa
or another ocean world one day.
This concept could have some
type of legs to be able
to stabilize itself
on a really treacherous terrain
and a lot of engineers are
developing sampling tools
that could cut into very, very cold ice.
The European Space Agency
is also sending a probe in
the next couple of years
called the Jupiter Icy
Moons Explorer or JUICE.
It will spend at least
three years studying Jupiter
and the habitability of
three of Jupiter's moons:
Europa, Callisto and Ganymede.
The last of which was recently found
to have possible water vapor
coming from its surface.
And there are even more
ambitious proposals
to explore subsurface
oceans in the far future.
There are even robotic snakes.
There's one that's called EELS,
the Exobiology Extant Life Surveyor.
We love our acronyms at NASA.
This is something that could
slither down into cracks
or crevices where
biosignatures might be hiding,
potentially protected from radiation.
So there are all sorts of
exciting concepts on the horizon.
There are even like these hoppers
that could even take
some of that water ice
and then melt it and use
the steam to sort of puff
to bounce around, to
go to different places.
Finding even microorganisms
would undoubtedly change
our understanding of life
and the boundaries of the habitable zone,
the area around a star which
we think could support life
as we know it.
Really it's caused us to change
our ideas for where we might look for life
and how abundant habitable
conditions might be
in the universe.
Since many planets around other stars,
known as exoplanets,
are now thought to contain liquid water,
these expeditions may tell us more about
which of these planets
are potentially habitable
and bring us closer to
answering the age-old question
of are we alone.
Ever since we, as human beings,
first started to look up
and wonder about stars,
about other planets, other worlds.
We wondered if we were alone.
You know, this universe is so
vast, so immense, so amazing.
Are there other worlds that could be
more incredibly diverse
beyond our wildest dreams
and have life of their own?
Or are we just incredibly, horribly alone?
I hope it's the first one.